the first six weeks of fall have been
unusually warm in much of this country
this week that will change with the
coldest air of the new season moving
into northern areas meteorologist megan
glaros is here in the studio to show us
where people need to bundle up i say
megan we can start here in the studio
welcome to you in times square it's good
to see you nice to see you too nate tony
gail you're absolutely it's a little
chilly in here so i'm with you on that
one i should have worn pants let's take
a look we've got snowshoe west virginia
today which by the way is actually
getting snow you mentioned it's been so
warm now we see not only signs of fall
but potentially signs of winter to come
this is the first blast of actual cold
weather that we've had in recent days
and in fact want to take a look at this
because chilly afternoon temperatures
are on tap for cities like chicago at 45
that's 11 degrees below normal wichita
43 that's 21 degrees below normal and a
similar setup in oklahoma city and also
in lubbock little rock coming in at 54
degrees so clearly getting a bit colder
across the area when we take a look at
the morning temperatures this is
something that we want to mention
because it has been so warm in the
mornings and that's changing as well
today 28 in chicago we're going to have
freeze warnings all the way from danbury
down to charlottesville in fact we have
had days on end about 50 degrees such a
very warm stretch for chicago 138 days
above 50. boston 140 days above 50. so
that brings me to this the warmest
morning temperatures in october ever for
more than 100 cities we're talking about
10 degrees above normal in detroit seven
in chicago and eight in pittsburgh so
that's why this blast of cold is gonna
feel so cold because it's been so mild
we've had such a warm fall yeah we were
getting spoiled sure we're coming to an
end though i don't even know where my
code is in fact i got caught this
morning too cold no jacket
happening to most of it i just want to
say well done you look like tom cruise
in the minority report did you like that
move well done thank you megan and to
quote adele rumor has it you're going to
be here all week yes we're glad that
we're going to do it glad you're here